so let's just say the revolution does
happen Okay let's just say this is a
different one and it's going to actually
take place okay
who's running the place what's the form
of the government who steps up you know
who are uh some names you you know for
the longest time you know many of the
Iranians who love the Shah they're like
you know his son is going to go back and
Farah and Reza pallavi and they're going
to go back and you know that's what's
gonna happen you're hearing the news you
know soccer player legendary soccer
player Ali Academy you know going around
saying what he's saying because
typically when you do have a revolution
a British Diplomat wrote a book like 20
years 15 years ago called leaderless
Revolution who's the leader today it's a
leaderless revolution right it's like
the prime example of there's a
revolution taking place without a leader
what's gonna happen if this revolution
does take place this is the biggest
characteristics that this event has it
right now which is why it's literally
there is an event going on 25 days in a
country with no exact or no person as a
leading it and here's the problem with
in my opinion from the outside the
country leaders or even inside the
country yeah imagine a one row one-way
line bridge and you're parking at the
middle of it you're not backing up that
people go and you're not going forward
that people some of our leaders are
standing at the middle of the bridge and
they're not letting people one day they
are king one day they are not King one
day they want to be completed one day
they don't want one day they're a
resident they announced that I'm just a
resident this thing is not we can't
count on the people that they're all on
outside the country I believe that next
future leader of the country would be a
possibly a lady
from the street after you think so look
at what the girls are doing that's
amazing look at what the teenage girls
they're leading the charge right now
that'd be great demonstrating you know
yeah I mean but but you know how uh uh
when there's a crisis leaders rise up
and you kind of identify certain names
like hey you look at what happened here
boom who's this person never knew this
person overnight we know the person are
there some names that are being you know
identified who are getting their voices
to get louder and louder I haven't heard
anything and also it's I would say even
if I had it's dangerous to say it
because you're just giving something
away and like oh well then we're gonna
go watch this person I understand that
no but what you say when you said Ali
Karimi I think people half joke and half
think well he would be great if he could
come back and do that right
um no but I have also heard people say
just this is not anything formal this is
just like oh this would be cool if this
happened but there's a human rights
lawyer that famously has never left the
country and they jail her all the time
for defending human
and you said a female people have been
like well she'd be great if you know she
could leave Iran out of all the
countries is ready to have an A Woman as
a president well not in the current
government no no no of course once the
revolution happens you think it's
capable to do that and if you do uh
Khomeini came in he killed two thousand
of Shahs generals and military leaders
what do you do if you do take over
hezbollah's are still there morality
police people are still there what do
you do them jailed them like a hundred
thousand people gonna go to jail I mean
that's a because those if they're still
out there they're gonna do what their
job is to do are they going to escape
and go to you know where are they going
to go to what do you do with those folks
well the Imperial Army when Shaw left a
lot of them just switched over they were
like okay well I guess you're not
allowed no no he killed a lot of me
killed like a couple thousand of them
and a lot of them top ones yeah they got
the top ones yeah
well yeah I mean those are the main ones
you gotta figure out because you you
need your lieutenants you need your
generals but uh what happens with that
what do you do with that do you what
happens with the Hezbollah laws what
happens with these you know these people
you know history shows during the Mosaic
time
and uh even a couple of times after that
that these people they have a fantastic
Talent of over the night changing face
we saw that at 11 40 a.m people were in
their street that will show
the the 28 uh two months passed between
the people saying people say the
opposite things 20 minutes later when
that happened what do you mean by that
so you're saying they have to change
their minds is what you're saying many
people look at our celebrities look at
our celebrities in past months
I have a Farsi page has
as as soon as I came out of the country
on Facebook
I contact many celebrities that about
this matter you want to say something
about this matter you want to say
something nothing nothing
now last 15 20 days they feel like oh it
looks like this is serious they start
saying so and some of them still they're
not
clearing their position they're just
saying something between display and
that way that I don't I don't say that
taking aside
it's not a Time to Say
uh I'm personally sure I'm touchy I'm
the you know a soccer team soccer teams
which side it's a matter right now you
have shut up or your bisharaph that's it
right that's it and they threatened
Shadow can you explain what no I can't
it's having having why isn't having
shame yeah so if you're be shut off you
have no no shame yeah no [ __ ] shame
and the artists do get threatened and
their families get threatened and I know
they've taken people's passports away so
they can't leave the country so we yes
it would be and a lot of them have
spoken out and then they get threatened
and so it's like they try to do it and
they can't go past a certain point
because of what's being
told that will happen to them and their
families so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
thank you